Predominância estrogênica pode causar
fogachos? Excelente pergunta. Hoje eu
vou conversar com vocês sobre uma
questão que gera muita confusão e até
mesmo entre profissionais de saúde. Será
que a predominância estrogênica pode
causar fogachos? Essa pergunta aparece
direto no meu consultório e olha, faz
todo sentido a dúvida. Sabe aquelas
ondas de calor que parecem uma fornalha
ligando dentro do corpo? Pois é, os
famosos fogachos. A maioria das pessoas
acham que é coisa só da menopausa, mas
calma lá que a história não bem assim.
Eu vou explicar bem direitinho para
vocês entenderem esse quebra cabeça
hormonal. Primeiro, deixa eu contar uma
história para vocês. Semana passada
atendi uma paciente de 42 anos que
chegou no consultório suando em bicas
toda vermelha dizendo: "Doutor, tô na
menopausa, pedi os exames e adivinha? Os
níveis de estrogênio dela estavam nas
alturas. Como assim, né? Forsto com
estrogênio alto, é aí que mora o perigo
de simplificar demais as coisas.
O que acontece é o seguinte, nosso corpo
funciona como uma orquestra sinfônica.
Não adianta ter 50 violinos tocando se
não tem nenhum violoncé para equilibrar
o som. Então com os hormônios é a mesma
coisa. A predominância ou dominância
estrogênica acontece quando o estrogênio
tá desproporcional em relação
progesterona, não necessariamente quando
ele tá alto em valores absolutos. E olha
que interessante, quando esse
desequilíbrio acontece, o hipotálamo,
que é um órgão que tá dentro do nosso
cérebro, é o nosso termostato interno,
ele pode ficar meio bugado. É como se o
ar condicionado da sua casa começasse a
funcionar mal, porque alguém mexeu nas
configurações. O resultado pode sim
aparecer fogacho mesmo com estrogênio
sobrando. Mas pera aí, não é só isso.
Predominância ou dominância estrogênica
vem acompanhada de uma turma de sintomas
chatos para caramba. Seios inchados e
doloridos, retenção de líquido que faz a
gente parecer um balão, irritabilidade
que até a mosca voando incomoda, ciclo
menstrual bagunçado, TPM que parece que
nunca acaba, é um pacote completo de
incômodos. E sabe o que mais? Hoje em
dia a gente tá cercado de xenoestrógeno.
São substâncias químicas que imitam a
ação do estrogênio no nosso corpo, se
ligam ao receptor estrogênico. Então, no
plástico da garrafinha de água, nos
cosméticos, nos agrotóxicos, é como se a
gente estivesse numa sopa de hormônios
artificiais.
Não é à toa que cada vez mais mulheres
jovens aparecem com sintomas de
predominância ou dominância estrogênica.
Agora vamos combinar uma coisa, nem todo
o fogacho é predominância frogênica, OK?
Na verdade, a maioria das vezes,
especialmente depois de 45 anos, os
calorões são mesmo deficiência falta de
estrogênio. É a menopausa chegando e
fazendo a festa. Mas em mulheres mais
novas ou naquelas que usam
anticoncepcional faz muito tempo ou que
tem uma alimentação rica em carboidratos
finados, alimentação inflamatória cheia
de açúcar, aí sim pode ser o excesso
relativo causando confusão no sistema. O
diagnóstico correto faz toda a
diferença, pessoal. Imagina tratar
predominante estrogênica como se fosse
menopausa. Seria como já gasolina no
fogo. Por isso que a medicina funcional
olha o quadro todo. Não só os homôos
sexuais, mas também tireoide, cortisol,
insulina, tá tudo conectado. E o
tratamento? Ah, aí que tá o pulo do
gato. Não é só tomar um remedinho
pronto. A gente tem que limpar o fígado
para ele metabolizar melhor os
hormônios, aumentar o consumo de fibras
para eliminar o excesso estrogênio pelo
intestino, reduzir o estresse que
bagunça tudo, fazer exercício físico que
ajuda no equilíbrio hormonal. É um
trabalho de formiguinha, mas que vale
muito a pena, apesar que muitas vezes
pode demorar esse processo. Tem também
os fitormônios e a progesteron
biidêntica ou isomolecular, que podem
ajudar muito quando bem indicados. Mas
olha, cada caso é um caso que funciona
pra sua vizinha, pode não funcionar para
você. O corpo de cada mulher é único com
suas particularidades e necessidades
específicas. Então, resumindo a ópera,
sim, a dominância ou predominância
estrogênica pode causar fogachos, mas
não é o mais comum. Se você tá tendo
ondas de calor e tem por volta de 45
anos, vale investigar se não é um
desequilíbrio hormonal ao invés de
menopausa precoce. E mesmo que seja
menopausa, não é o fim do mundo. Hoje em
dia temos tantas opções de tratamento
que dá para passar por essa fase com
qualidade de vida. O importante é não
sofrer calada, achando que é normal, tá
bom? Procure um profissional que entenda
de medicina funcional de hormônios, faça
os exames certinhos e vamos equilibrar
essa orquestra hormonal, porque mulher
merece viver bem em todas as fases da
vida com o sem fogacho. Yeah.